[Música]
eu vou contar pra vocês uma história de
três irmãos que queriam ter a sua
própria casa
para isso eles precisavam encontrar um
lugar seguro e materiais para começar a
construção
os dois irmãos mais novos ele estavam
mais ansiosas em brincar e não queriam
perder muito tempo nesse processo
por isso eles usaram a o material que
encontraram com mais facilidade um deles
o palha o outro a madeira
o irmão mais velho ele estava muito mais
preocupado em construir uma casa segura
contra todo tipo de adversidade e aí por
isso ele usou um pouco mais de tempo e
acabou usando o tijolo que é o material
mais firme e aí o que aconteceu
chegou o famoso lobo mau
lobo em questão de segundos destruiu as
duas casas mais frases deixando os dois
irmãos mais novos desabrigados
eles foram correndo pra casa do irmão
mais velho e lá eles de fato conseguiram
ficar seguros contra o lobo lobo sem
sucesso foi embora nunca mais voltou
e os três irmãos viveram felizes para
sempre
casar para a grande maioria das pessoas
está associado a vestir branco trocar
alianças reformar o apartamento e abrir
mão da antiga casa
refletir sobre a relação nos dias que
virão é tão desvalorizado que só se
pensa nisso quando provocado por um
padre ou um advogado por questões
normalmente mais burocráticas como se
vão mudar o sobrenome ou qual vai ser o
regime matrimonial estabelecido
dessa forma o que vocês acham que não se
preocupa não as pessoas não costumam se
preocupar em falar sobre alguma coisa
que é tão importante como o casamento
eu acredito que pelo mesmo motivo que o
fez com que os porquinhos mais novos não
se preocupassem em construir uma casa
segura contra o lobo mau
eles estavam tão entretidos com os
prazeres e meio
gatos a brincadeira estava boa demais
pra eles cortarem o barato pensando
nessa trabalheira toda ae sei lá
parece até que pensar tanto em se
proteger do lobo atrair o lobo a nossa
vida amorosa é toda construída sobre o
paradigma da alma gêmea
a gente acredita que o nosso parceiro
deve fazer eco a todas as nossas
aspirações e danos
esse é um mito que atravessa a história
por gerações através dos contos de fadas
e romances e faz com que a gente
acredite o nosso íntimo acima de
qualquer razão que existe uma pessoa no
mundo que nos completa ou como se diz
popularmente é a nossa metade da laranja
e aí o nosso maior desafio será
encontrar entre 7 bilhões de pessoas no
mundo
essa de nos tornar inteiro tarefa fácil
né
é bom chegou a hora de uma triste
revelação
depois da decepção infantil que tivemos
de que papai noel não existe
já tá na hora de sabermos a nossa alma
gêmea também não sabe aquela sensação de
completude de que a gente se fala no
olhar isso não acontece porque somos
iguais e sim porque há muita intimidade
e muita cumplicidade
depois de se conhecer e reconhecer a
diferença do outro o grande perigo dessa
idéia da alma gêmea é que quando a gente
parte do princípio que o outro com quem
casar anos é a nossa metade e portanto
penso igual a gente a gente acaba por
não checar e começa a agir em cima de
suposições e a gente supõe então que por
exemplo uma coisa que para mim é o
máximo a gente dá de presente para o
outro sem nem supor que pro outro ponto
não tem tanto valor
e aí a gente casa numa é supondo que a
gente vai continuar a vida
da mesma forma como sempre se deu em
nossa família numa completa negação de
que o outro com quem casamos vem de
outro lugar e portanto teve outro
a criação no meu caso por exemplo as
nossas diferenças começaram a gritar
logo na primeira compra de mercado eu
valorizar os produtos orgânicos a saúde
ele os preços
as marcas dos produtos também eram
motivo de discussão ali na volta para
casa além das sacolas a gente carregava
junto daquelas sacola e também as nossas
frustrações que a frustrante né a gente
sempre acha que com a gente vai ser
diferente porque gente são coisas assim
bem simples que causam grandes
discórdias na vida de um casal portanto
todas essas diferenças elas podem
aparecer ao longo do dedo de diversos
acontecimentos do ciclo vital não pode
ser por exemplo a construção da nova
casa como eu citei mas também pode ser
no nascimento e na educação dos filhos
ou até também em questões mais
rotineiras assim do dia a dia como a
distribuição de tarefas domésticas ou
com a organização financeiro é no meu
consultório no dia a dia lá do
consultório eu vejo os clássicos ter ou
não ter cachorro televisão ou não no
quarto
comer na mesa ou no sofá em frente à tv
e por aí segue uma lista infinita de
diferenças que eu escuto todo santo dia
parece brincadeira mas essa é a
realidade que chega no meu consultório é
nesse tipo de desencontro que os casais
chegam para terapia e vocês podem estar
por aqui pensando ah mas são questões
tão corriqueiras assim acontece com todo
mundo será que isso seria mesmo motivo
de preocupação
o que eu posso garantir para vocês é que
é essas são verdadeiras bombas que podem
desencadear grandes crises porque por
trás de todas essas pequenas rixas tem
uma criança perigosa de que a nossa
família os nossos hábitos e valores
são melhores e devem prevalecer
e não adianta a gente pode namorar uma
pessoa há anos que algumas coisas passam
despercebidos são particularidade que no
dia a dia de um namoro passam batidas e
aí quando a gente casa coisas simples é
coisas simples que é um som detalhe
passam a ser motivo de total estranheza
e aí é de repente começa a aflorar
aquele lado pequeno nosso começa a vir
uma começa uma guerra de força e começa
a aflorar aquele lado pequeno que chega
nos envergonha ea gente faz comentários
do tipo 1 1 mas sua mãe é muito cafona
se eu não te ensinou que não só o branco
é que a chicken existem claros choques
maiores que outros mas a verdade é que
sempre há a necessidade de adaptação e
para essa adaptação no casamento é
necessário a noção de que há a noção de
que o certo e errado é é uma noção
individual ou seja é construída a partir
do que cada um recebeu e viveu na sua
própria família e portanto subjetivo
então a gente precisa reconhecer a
subjetividade das próprias convicções
pra gente conseguir respeitar o universo
de quem é diferente da gente e nem por
isso errado casar se torna então uma
enorme oportunidade da gente se
modificar a gente conseguir humildemente
é rever todas as nossas os nossos
valores da gente generosamente ouvir o
outro estar para o outro é a gente sair
do salto de quem é dono da verdade e
treinar o nosso olhar empático para
conseguir aceitar respeitar o universo
dessa pessoa que está ao nosso lado
ironicamente às vezes tão distante onde
quero chegar com tudo isso eu junto com
minhas sócias
resolvemos ir na contramão de tudo que a
gente aprendeu na faculdade e ao invés
de trabalhar na crise que é a
consequência a gente resolveu voltar a
esse filme para trás e trabalhar o antes
ou como a gente gosta de dizer de
véspera a gente junto aos casais elabora
o projeto daquele casamento construindo
tijolo por tijolo daquela relação a
gente negocia todos os acordos que vão
reger aquela relação do casal sair dali
juntos de mãos dadas parceiro naquela
vida 2
dessa forma o casamento é como lá na
casa dos três porquinhos o casamento
precisa ter planejamento e construção
precisa ter pilares sólidos paredes
seguras e portas firmes porque desse
jeito não tem ventania incêndio ou logo
mal que consiga destruir o que foi ali
construído e aí desse jeito eu pergunto
a vocês quem aqui tem medo do lobo mau
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]